[Music]
season five Game of Thrones aired Sunday
as usual in this series a lot of
characters were killed did you watch
that even Andy yeah you know I have to
admit I was a little confused about who
has a claim to the Iron Throne at this
point right yeah Tommen didn't have
children and there are no other male
heirs left so Cersei took it over and
yeah well I you know I mean maybe
there's a male heir out there they just
haven't found him yet oh look it's a
raven it's got some kind of note let
aunty finish taki before you cut to me
it says greetings I'm pleased to inform
you Andrew firstborn from the house of
Bricker that you are the rightful heir
to the Iron Throne how cool is that this
is so amazing very cool Congrats
thank you very much Oh another Raven
Joss all time you don't need that let me
get the gum off ya legs
to claim the throne please wire fifty
thousand gold coins to the iron bank of
Nigeria via Western Union oh it has a
bank routing number that's easy I'm
sorry I'm that's awesome it'll mean
can't you just be happy that something
Goods happening to me for once oh look
another one they should write smaller
and just send it on one raid yeah well
you know Ravens need to work Andy will
need your social security number to
verify the transaction please email it
to king of westeros and not scam dot biz
okay Andy clearly that's not a legit
email address it's one of those scam
aru's yeah I guess you're right
still I do wonder where all these Ravens
are coming from
what do you mean he said no scam but
that's why I put not scam in the email
what I thought this is a legitimate
domain it's just cheaper oh come on
don't tell me he didn't want the penis
enlargement pills well more for me I
guess hmm sex party
[Applause]
he's choking on his penis pills he
should have a giant penis when he stands
I don't need this many he should have a
huge codpiece when he stands up or knock
the table over how come my Ravens have
have feathers and is his are all smooth
your Ravens look shitty
[Music]
you